this is only the second time the Justice
Department has appointed a special
counsel under the current rules Jan
Crawford is CBS News chief legal
correspondent John Jann so as Special
Counsel
how much power Moe Muller had to
investigate the Trump's campaign ties to
Russia well I mean Nora this is
wide-ranging and it could expand I mean
in his letter Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosen Stein gives Muller significant
power to investigate any links and/or
coordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the campaign a president Donald
Trump and other matters that may arise
directly from the investigation now the
Deputy Attorney General will oversee
Miller's work and he technically has the
power to end the investigation but
Muller won't be subject to the
day-to-day supervision and if Rosenstein
were to block any mother's actions he'd
have to give an explanation to Congress
now in the past special counsels have
been governed by the judiciary and the
thinking there was just to make sure
that there's no interference from the
executive branch we all of course
remember ken starr's wide-ranging
investigation into Bill Clinton that was
overseen by a panel of three judges not
the Justice Department but people on
both sides of the aisle had issues with
that Starr investigation so when that
provision expired in 1999 the oversight
power went back to the Justice
Department Gail Jan thank you very much